one of the things that's interesting
about this film i guess mike and i don't
know how much you can say about the the
last installment of halloween but um
where are you guys in the writing
process have you do you guys can you
talk about where you are in the
scripting process yeah well i mean a
week ago i said we're done and then a
few bright ideas and conversations like
this that inspire me and and then i i
and i'm reunited with a lot of the cast
members and doing the the press junket
and so i think
so i'm just and watching the movie with
a new
new eye
so i did get to work this weekend and
made some revisions and i'll be doing
that until we're done editing you know
we we really do
keep ourselves as writers um i've got
two new
writing collaborators on this with with
me and danny uh paul logan and chris
bernier who are just huge halloween fans
and so we always try to bring new voices
into the mix and so they they poke holes
in our story and they play devil's
advocate and they bring new ideas and
new reference points and
so yeah this weekend all weekend i was
rampaging on a new new pass of it but we
start prep
uh in two weeks and and so they're
wanting me to lock in something more
definitive which i think will be in good
shape for that to shoot in january
do you mind can i ask if you're going to
does the next film the third film uh
does it start right after the second
film ends the way you did it with the
second film or is there a time jump it's
a time jump it gets back back on to a um
uh contemporary timeline so it'll jump
four years
uh it's interesting because i was i was
thinking you had to do something like
that because you want to have you know
jamie more in the action not suffering
from like a stomach
kind of you know what i mean yeah it's a
big thing and you know a lot of this
movie was tricky not only in writing the
shape and his lack of character but but
keeping her
um in a realistic scenario you know
there's a very there's a graphic surgery
that we film of her and and then once
you've done that it's not she's not
going to be doing a lot of kung fu so
100 um do you envision the the your
third film as like the ending of the
halloween saga do you want it to
continue after you're done
i mean my ego says create something that
is a four-part
series beginning with carpenter's 1978
film and then our our follow-up trilogy
and i'm sure the mythology takes over
and michael and laurie will emerge in
some new capacity with some new
filmmaker storyteller behind them but
for me
uh i'll i'll be done and and i hope
they'll take a little time off before
they resuscitate it but that's just my
ego yeah
um when do you actually film the movie
in january
uh okay so you're a few months so oh i
got it so is that no that's cool so you
have a few months to really get it
together
uh
yeah i guess you could call it that
let me say a few months to get the
script you know what i'm saying yeah the
script's in great shape it's just a
matter of like you know committing to
certain paths and and uh and characters
and
and constructing new set pieces and then
you get into the realities of schedule
and budget and people say
you know what happens if you lose that
scene you save some time and money and
can use that somewhere else i don't know
you know you get into that type of
massage
so i never look at anything it's done
until we're sound mixing